[Música]
muy buenos días antes de nada me
gustaría que ellos imaginarios la
siguiente situación imaginaos que estáis
realizando un vuelo un vuelo
trasatlántico nocturno vale y bueno
estáis aprovechando para echar un
sueñecito el avión está apagado vale
está básicamente todo el mundo durmiendo
pero de repente el avión pasa por una
zona de turbulencias se mueve mucho eso
provoca que las luces de cabina se
enciendan os despertáis y la primera
imagen que veis es esta
una situación en fin bueno os voy a dar
tres alternativas de posible situación
que se está produciendo aquí vale y
luego os voy a pedir que votéis vale qué
queréis que está ocurriendo realmente la
primera situación es que es una pareja
de recién casados vale que está camino
de su luna de miel pero no puede llegar
vale al rancho de bodas la segunda
alternativa es que se han conocido en la
puerta de embarque y bueno pues en fin
amor a primera vista vale y la tercera
alternativa es que bueno son una pareja
profesional y además de ellos son
amantes vale
quien considera que es la primera opción
muy bien algunas manos levantadas muy
bien quien considera que es la segunda
se han conocido en la puerta de embarque
amor a primera vista vale suben y quien
considera que tiene una relación
profesional y son amantes
ostras
no sé exactamente qué puede querer
significar esto
pero bueno en fin queréis conocer la
respuesta correcta si es esta
abajo
el árbol
se está haciendo pis la señora desde
luego qué mal pensado son en fin esto
tiene que ver con el hecho de que nos
encanta montarnos películas
nos encanta contarnos películas pero
sabes que es lo mejor lo mejor es que
necesitamos montarnos películas el ser
humano necesita darle un sentido a las
cosas que están ocurriendo para poder
moverse y si no lo encuentra se lo
inventa
evidentemente se lo inventa con la
información de la que en un momento
determinado puede disponer pero aquí
llega el segundo gran problema tenemos
tal cantidad de información a nuestro
alrededor y tan poco tiempo para filtrar
la que necesitamos atajos y por ese
motivo ponemos etiquetas a las personas
fulanito es un vago menganita en fin
jolín es que antipática es no me saluda
por las mañanas por este motivo también
nos encantan los titulares de los
periódicos aunque no a veces leemos las
noticias completas y por este motivo
también nos encantan los mensajes que
aparecen en las tazas de desayuno
este es un tema que a mí reconozco que
me tiene muy preocupado porque porque es
que literalmente nos bebemos los
mensajes cada mañana vale pero no no no
no nos leemos la letra pequeña voy a no
sé en vuestras tazas pero desde luego
mis tazas no aparecen las letras
pequeñas y todos tiene otras pequeñas
todo el mundo sabe en esta sala que no
todo tiene que ver con las ganas vale o
es que aquí hay gente que no tiene ganas
de tener un dinerito en la cuenta y
realmente luego no lo tienen pues que
sepáis que es porque no tenía ganas yo
creo que son mensajes que bueno que sí
que efectivamente nos ayudan a
interpretar la realidad de una manera
muy sencilla a tomar decisiones de una
manera más o menos rápida pero hay que
tener cuidado hay que tener cuidado con
las etiquetas con los titulares que
ponemos porque es que además el
verdadero problema de las etiquetas y
los titulares que ponemos a las cosas y
de las películas que nos montamos es que
en función de la película si actuamos
pues fijaos la vida de este pobre pez
a este pez le ha etiquetado
un gato con la etiqueta sabroso alimento
imaginaos la conducta subyacente y el
niño está viendo un juguete maravilloso
por lo tanto la vida del pez tiene un
futuro completamente distinto lo verdad
es importante de las etiquetas o de
tener cuidado con las etiquetas que
necesitamos para vivir eso por supuesto
necesitamos etiquetas para poder tomar
decisiones rápidas lo grande importante
es que tenemos que ser cuidado y
cuidadosos con cuáles ponemos o con qué
reflexiones un poco más profundas
hacemos a la hora de elegir las digamos
no por eso a mí me preocupa
especialmente las etiquetas que ponemos
a los jóvenes vale
la gente de mi generación los 40 los
saber 50 sobre 60 los over vale los que
ya no cumplimos los 40 cuando cuando nos
preguntamos o cuando preguntamos a la
gente de nuestra edad pues como
caracteriza a la gente joven
sistemáticamente surgen tres etiquetas
vale la etiqueta de que son pasotas de
que no se comprometen por nada
la etiqueta de que viven pegados a una
pantalla de ordenador
o de móvil y la etiqueta de que son
impacientes vale bueno yo esto me lo
cuestiono radicalmente por la
experiencia que yo he podido tener con
ellos en los últimos años pasotas no los
mayores los over 40 hemos construido un
mundo de muchas oportunidades para los
jóvenes y eso hace que sean mucho más
selectivos con aquello a lo que se
comprometen pero puestos a comprometerse
nos dan lecciones de compromiso a los
mayores al menos esa es mi experiencia
digitales les ponemos esta etiqueta
señores por pura envidia
porque nos flipa cómo se mueven las
redes sociales cómo entiende la
tecnología las primeras de cambio y
nosotros por bueno entonces mi mujer
puede dar fe de que muchos de estos
jóvenes a mí me dan lecciones de cómo se
desconecta de un teléfono móvil por
ejemplo y no soy joven y lo impaciente
es completamente de acuerdo con quién
pone estas etiquetas a los jóvenes los
jóvenes hoy tienen está este eslogan o
muchos jóvenes tienen este eslogan de
que hay que vivir con 25 años lo que
quieras ver con 80 porque con 26 ya
estás muerto
así que ya sabemos cómo estamos muchos
aquí y entonces claro pues qué es lo que
ocurre con esto pues que las semanas las
semanas bueno una semana de paciencia
pero a la semana yo en fin
me cansé vale yo con este de la
impaciencia estoy completamente de
acuerdo es reconocerlo y yo me dedico a
la identificación y desarrollo de
talento joven desde hace muchos años y
en los últimos tres hemos desarrollado
una investigación que se denomina los
impulsores del talento que nos ha
permitido conocer con mucha más
profundidad a esta juventud no a esta
juventud a la que habitualmente la
consideramos como de futuro pero no es
una generación de futuro es una
generación de presente totalmente
nos ha permitido escurrir tengo una
buena noticia hay una mala noticia para
vosotros no sé si preferís empezar por
la buena o por la mala
por la mala la mala es que en gran
medida la capacidad de los jóvenes para
poder identificar y desarrollar su
talento tiene que ver con todos vosotros
con los que sois padres de estos jóvenes
cuando hablo de jóvenes hablo de gente
de entre los 18 y los 26 28 más o menos
vale para poder centrar un poco el tiro
una gran responsabilidad está la tenemos
nosotros como padres como educadores
como jefes de estos jóvenes vale la
buena noticia no tienen nada que ver con
la genética
no con la vuestra cola de los jóvenes
quiero decir es decir cualquier joven
que se puede vivir un determinado tipo
de contexto a lo largo de su infancia y
adolescencia y en gran medida propiciada
evidentemente se busca la vida pero
también propiciada por sus educadores
por sus padres etcétera tiene la
oportunidad de poder identificar ese
talento con el cual comprometerse e
impulsarlo hacia adelante a mí me
gustaría compartir cuáles son
hemos descubierto unos cuantos no pero y
me gustaría compartir con vosotros
cuáles son los cuatro más importantes el
primero se denomina curiosidad
divergente vale hemos descubierto que
los jóvenes para poder identificar y
desarrollar su talento necesitan estar a
mil cosas a la vez
amigos el niño en el bautizo el novio en
la boda y el muerto en el entierro y si
no no tiran palante entonces si no me da
la vida pablo no no sé qué pasa que es
que me canso mucho contar se ha cansado
si es que estás de voluntario no sé qué
entrenando no sé cuántos ayudando un
amiguete con no sé cuántos y encima
tienes que ir a clase y estudiar
pues pues así es muy difícil que llegue
pero yo desde luego como padres como
educadores de estos jóvenes os invito a
que claramente en lugar de decirles
estudia esta clase estudia vete clase
estudia vete clase les digáis explora
explora nuestra experiencia es que esto
les ayuda a identificar su talento ya
desarrollarlo pueden bajar un poquito
las notas mejor si aquí hay jóvenes
ahora que no escuchen vale
pueden bajar un poquito las notas pero
de brazos digo a los profesionales a los
a las empresas no les gustan los jóvenes
que tienen masters del universo y que
esa cantidad es en todo y que luego
las cosas pintan mal y se meten de
alguna mesa esto no le gusta a nadie
vale por tanto a lo mejor merece la pena
que menos foco en expediente en notas en
clases etcétera y pongamos más foco en
abrir abanico vale este es el primer
aprendizaje el segundo aprendizaje tiene
que ver con la identidad los jóvenes
para poder identificar y desarrollar su
talento necesitan descubrir quiénes son
y quiénes quieren ser
pero descubrir lo de ellos
no que se lo descubramos nosotros
necesitan pensar reflexionar analizar
poder opinar y no encontrarse al otro
lado alguien que le tiza tonterías
escucha una cosa esto es así hazme caso
que tengo mucha experiencia
los jóvenes necesitan descubrir ellos
mismos su identidad debemos invitarles a
reflexionar por sí mismos para que la
descubran luego expresan su identidad en
fin de aquella manera a lo mejor les
podemos ayudar con esto no el otro día
hacía una entrevista con una de estas
jóvenes le preguntaba esta entrevista de
selección le decía cuál cuál sería
cristina que es tu principal defecto
me dice pablo mi principal defecto es
que soy insultantemente sincera
me senté en la silla vale ya estoy
preparado dime cuál es tu principal
defecto
expresa en su identidad de tal manera
que en algunas ocasiones pues pueden
generar un determinado tipo de
incomodidad de malestar en la gente no a
lo mejor les podemos ayudar a expresar
su identidad pero dejemos de esquel a
creen por ellos mismos tercer impulsor
del talento la porosidad los jóvenes a
diferencia a lo mejor de un poquito más
mayores no los over
40 50 60 a los jóvenes tienen los poros
muy abiertos entonces todo lo sienten en
grandísima medida y están muy alegres y
están muy tristes y tienen miedo y de
repente se sorprenden y tienen alegría
qué guay esto es estar vivo
dejémosles que sientan es muy curioso
como muchísimos de los jóvenes con los
que hemos trabajado a lo largo de estos
años no solamente tienen una porosidad
brutal sino que además necesitan
expresarla a través de algún tipo de
mecanismo artístico muchísimos jóvenes
aparte de lo que es puedan dedicar o lo
que puedan estar estudiando
académicamente o tocan la guitarra o
hacen fotografía o escriben poesía
necesitan expresar hacia afuera todo lo
que sienten dejémosles les vendrá bien
para poder impulsar ese talento que es
algo que necesitamos todos y el último
impulsor que me gustaría compartir con
vosotros es la generosidad que yo creo
que es el que más nos distingue a las
generaciones pues quizá no lo millennial
pues millennial etcétera de generaciones
anteriores como la generación x o los
baby boomers cuando lo de generosidad no
hablo de que te inviten a las copas a
los cafés
yo también esta no es mi experiencia y
que quede bien claro
si no tienen este tipo de generosidad
ver la generosidad en el esfuerzo no
miden el esfuerzo
no hacen cálculos acerca de si dicen en
una reunión tal cosa porque como esta
fulanito eso puede dar lugar a que claro
aproveche la idea esto los jóvenes no lo
hacen
los jóvenes se entregan desde el punto
de vista de lo que es su esfuerzo sus
ideas sus opiniones y por supuesto
valoran enormemente que en su entorno la
gente actúe del mismo modo y hay una
cosa muy importante que no me gustaría
olvidarme de contaros no tienen un
compromiso social diferencial
más vale que nos pongamos las pilas con
esto o vamos a tener dificultad con
ellos si no tenemos este compromiso
social que ellos necesitan de sus
organizaciones de los ecosistemas en los
cuales se muevan bueno vamos a ir
terminando
me gustaría para terminar contaros una
historia de mi juventud yo también fui
joven os vais a creer siglo 12 pero pero
pero yo también fui joven en su momento
no yo recuerdo mi padre es el filósofo
filósofo de formación vale nunca ha
ejercido profesionalmente la filosofía
como por otro lado casi nadie
pero imaginaos con quién ejercía la
filosofía mi padre
y hermanas impresionante las chapas
pues el día antes de ponerme a trabajar
con 22 años para trabajar cometí dos
años me coge por bandas me dice pablo
éxito sería como se pone el necesito
tener una conversación contigo ahora que
empieza una nueva etapa en tu vida yo
quiero recordar que tenía entradas para
el baloncesto aquel día me dije dios
se acabaron las entradas
pero él me debió leer la cara y es un
consejo solamente de pablo es un consejo
sólo va a ser muy rápido un consejo
rápido está bien papá no es un consejo
que me gustaría compartir con vosotros
para terminar porque a mí me ha servido
mucho siempre decía recuerda a partir de
ahora que las cosas nunca ocurren porque
sí
siempre ocurren por algo
entonces si no entiendes por qué están
ocurriendo las cosas profundiza
reflexiona pregunta no hagas juicios
rápidos yo os invitaría a que todos los
que tenéis padres a los que seis padres
de jóvenes a todos los que sois
profesores de jóvenes a todos los que
sois jefes de jóvenes cuando no
entendáis por qué dicen lo que dicen
porque piensan lo que piensan porque
actúan como actúan reflexionar es un
poquito más sobre ello identificar es un
poquito más los motivos de fondo que
puede subyacer a esa conducta porque eso
nos ayudaría y nos ayudaría a poder
ayudarles muchísimo más en ese ejercicio
de impulso de su talento que tanto
necesitan muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]